i think personally everything that can
be easily automated is eventually going
to be easily automated in the
construction industry and automation i
use the term robot kind of
interchangeably for automation um
so for the purpose of this talk please
you know give me that and not you know
get too technical about it um
but it's kind of equivalent to
automation in general and also i'm here
i'm honestly i'm really talking about
for all intents and purposes like weak
ai i'm not getting into like crazy
singularity strong ai what the future
could be like a thousand years from now
okay
um
so
current this is today right today robots
do my drafting
okay so i don't draft things anymore uh
there's a whole new thing that came out
about started using it about 10 years
ago
this concept called bim which is
building information management not
going to get to or building information
modeling not getting too technical here
but the basic idea see that top left
there okay that's an image of the 3d
model of one of the buildings out at the
ucf medical center
right the new medical buildings they're
giant machines just wrapped in a pretty
skin so that they're not scary to us
people when we go there um like
seriously they're incredibly complex
right so trying to navigate that kind of
a project with 2d drawings on paper is
almost impossible right so this whole
bim system basically what you do is you
describe to the computer in
high detail what the building is made
out of and then that system then
produces a lot of the drawings plans
sections elevations all that kind of
stuff that you need to submit to the
building department okay so robots are
already doing our drafting um robots are
also doing our field measuring this is a
laser scan of a um
of a
city square in europe uh with the wonder
kim or the cabinet under the stairs here
we actually had a point cloud uh of the
interior space that somebody had done
and we were able to take you know the
laser measurements of that and then use
that to fabricate the cabinet that fits
right underneath there
and uh the other thing is this whole
idea that like this is from our friend's
company case tyler is raise your hand he
works for that company
so at any rate this whole idea that you
know it's more about data
uh than it is about drawing right and
also robots build my building so there's
this whole concept called digital
fabrication right where we have these
computer controlled tools that cut
things out so the things i draw on a
computer or that i model on the computer
uh these giant robots will then carve or
cut out those pieces for me and that's
how everything you see in here was made
like we didn't cut out that cabinet that
cabinet was cut out for us by robot
right
another really interesting thing this is
our one of our cnc machines we have one
of the older ones here so this is what
i'm talking about it's a giant cutting
robot in the top corner there that's
something called a total station it's a
really exciting new thing that's come
into existence the last 10 years or so
so they started making survey equipment
for job sites robotic so that one guy
could just walk around with a little
wand and gps mark points right and then
they're like well if that thing's
robotic why don't we put a pointing
laser on it and it can point where
stuff's supposed to go right so you feed
the cad model to it and it'll point with
a laser like oh yeah the anchors for the
pipes that you're going to hang six
months from now go there and there and
there and there you know and so it
created a feedback loop because you can
measure things on the site too with that
and then feed it back into the cad model
back into the bim model
so if something got put in the wrong
place you know exactly where it's at and
you can coordinate and all that kind of
stuff this is all stuff that's happening
today this is not
hoo-ha future this is really standard
kind of stuff uh prefabrication and
pre-production um i'm not talking about
the kind of hyped-up dwell like we're
gonna drop a house on a site kind of
pre-fabrication but like bathrooms now
are something on larger commercial
projects where they're just fabricating
those bathrooms as little units in a
factory and just bringing them out and
dropping them into the site with a crane
uh also the new apple ca the new
building that they're building on the
apple campus a bunch of the offices and
bathrooms are all getting prefabricated
in some fancy factory somewhere brought
out to the job site dropped into place
and a lot of that is heavily automated
in those factories and then lastly
uh this is a bit of a joke but there are
robotic bulldozers now uh robotic
bulldozers look exactly like normal
bulldozers which is why i put this
picture in there instead but uh
but uh
basically there's systems now where you
feed it the cad data of what the site is
supposed to be
and a driver just follows a line on a
screen on a gps and the blade of the
bulldozer automatically moves to grade
the site to make it have the shape that
it needs to have
right and they've been doing that for
like eight years now or something
trimble that has that whole front to
back set up it's pretty awesome stuff
[Music]
you